pour répondre à votre question est ce
que c'est grave après tout d'abord que
la gauche ait abandonné les classes
populaires oui parce que la valeur car
toutes les classes populaires et à pau 2
et la gauche qui est possible vers porte
la responsabilité et celle des
responsables politiques de gauche bon
parce que la valeur cardinale de la
gauche c'est la justice et la gauche n'a
pas assez pris en compte la façon dont
les classes populaires les classes
moyennes ont été percutés par la
mondialisation par la
désindustrialisation par
dynamic d'aménagement du territoire qui
effectivement pour reprendre les termes
de jérôme fourquet voit une france
triple a et une france des oubliés sans
service public 110 trop où il faut
prendre sa bagnole pour aller faire ses
courses au lidl à 20 km et c'est donc
c'est dramatique et il faut parler de
ces problèmes là l'emploi le travail ça
reste le coeur de la dignité des gens
qu'on demande et quant aux gens ce
qu'ils esquissent ce qu'ils sont ce qui
fait leur dignité dans la vie c'est
quand même leur travail donc il faut
parler de solutions pour remédier au
chômage de masse c'est le sens d'une
proposition que j'ai faite et que vous
avez mentionné au début celle d'une
garantie d'emploi en emploi pour tous et
des initiatives qui ont été des
expérimentations qui ont été faites ces
dernières années sur ces questions comme
territoire 0 chômeurs de longue durée
qui dans les campagnes dans les
quartiers populaires se dit le chômage
n'est pas une fatalité le chômage de
longue durée coûte plus cher à la
société
que coûte très cher à la société et
finalement pour le même prix on pourrait
financer directement des emplois pour
les personnes qui en sont privées et de
telle sorte que ce soit utile pour tous
est bénéfique pour tous donc ces
questions cette question du travail
effectivement est fondamental dans à
d'autres mais effectivement la gauche
s'est replié sur des thèmes
on dit souvent sociétaux qui sont
importants aussi mais elle a oublié
acquis à qui elle parlait
[Musique]